- [Siva] Hello everybody.
Thank you for coming in. Good afternoon.
My name is Siva Guruvareddiar.
I'm a senior specialist
architect here at AWS.
So welcome to this session on
comprehensive observability
with mobile real user
monitoring and application map.
So with me, I have Alex,
who is a principal engineer at AWS.
And we would like to talk about
this as a code talk, right?
We wanted to have it dive into the code
and then talk about the various features
and all those things, right?
But before getting into the beats,
how many of you here, like you know,
just show me your hands,
if you are using Application Signals
in your product or in your company?
Maybe that's a bad marketing on our side.
How many of you have heard
about Application Signals?
Good. Yeah.
So Application Signals is
our own way of doing APM,
application performance monitoring.
And I would like to level
set the field, like you know,
we will be taking a very short
maybe theoretical concept
on what is it all about.
Then we'll dive into the
coding things, right?
So this is what our agenda is gonna be.
We'll talk about the overview
on a very high level,
then we'll talk about the
latest and greatest features
including application map,
the mobile real user monitoring,
which we just launched
a couple of weeks back.
And finally, like you know,
we'll get into the code things.
So Application Signals, as I
said, it is on a high level,
you can think of it as our own version
of application performance monitoring.
So we have inventory of services
that you're running in your application
or like, in your account
and all those, right?
And you wanted to both
understand, like you know,
monitor it, and observe it,
and when things are failing,
you wanted to fix it ASAP.
So that's what it is all about.
So we will be showing, like you know,
irrespective of whether
you are instrumenting it
or not instrumenting it,
we'll be showing you all the services
that are available in your
account from the console.
We'll be showing a demo.
And also, like you know, it's
all based on golden metrics.
In the APM world, the
golden metrics is all
about RED metrics we call it as,
wherein R stands for request,
E stands for errors and the faults
and D stands for duration or latency.
So everywhere, like you know,
in Application Signals console,
whatever you'll be seeing
it's based on golden metrics,
or the RED metrics, and
dependency tracking.
But the beauty here is, like you know,
you're not sending us any kind of metadata
that says, like you know, okay,
hey, my service is calling service B.
We will be getting all
the tracing information
based on the distributed tracing,
and then we'll figure out
what is your dependency is.
It's all based on open standards.
We all using OpenTelemetry
as the underlying mechanism.
And using that, like you know,
we will be showing you all the details.
So with that one, like you know,
as a next level you wanna connect your,
maybe your technical things
with your business metrics.
So that's where you can create your SLOs,
service level objectives,
from your services.
And also, like you know,
the topology map will be
showing you how these
services are interrelated
with each other, as in
when your services are
sending metrics to us.
So with this one, like you
know, like we discussed,
it is based on distributed tracing,
and last year we introduced a
concept of transaction search.
So what we are doing is
we are taking your traces
and then storing as logs.
So in that case, like you
know, any kind of transactions
that are available in your
business applications,
you can go ahead and then search for it.
The typical way you'll be doing
with CloudWatch logs, right?
So we can do that.
And last but not least, like
you know, we have support
for real user monitoring
as well as canneries.
So real user monitoring
predominantly we have been
supporting web for a pretty long time.
And recently, like you
know, we added support
for mobile applications
both iOS and Android.
And as well as, like you
know, synthetic canneries,
if you wanted to run any
synthetic testing on your APIs,
on your endpoints, that is also supported.
So let's talk about the newer feature
called application map.
So it has come, like you
know, a lot of stages.
So we started with trace
map and service map.
Currently it is in the
stages of application map.
So application map it is,
so like, you're seeing
in the upper, like you know,
right hand side picture.
So that's how, like you
know, you will be seeing it.
We will be showing you the demo on this.
So here's where, like you know,
you'll be seeing a lot of tiles.
So these tiles are
representing your applications,
and then we are grouping
together by related services.
So that is our default grouping.
But you can go ahead
and then create your own custom grouping.
Either, like you know, there
is a front end grouping
and then there is a backend grouping.
Or if you are running, like
you know, multiple BUs,
for example, like you know,
I might be running a
JS application, right?
A financial application.
So that could be, like you know,
my BU could be a lone
BU, could be one tile,
and then my lending could
be another BU tile, right?
So that way you can go ahead
and then segregate your
applications the way you wanted it,
the way you wanted to observe it, right?
But the thing is, if you
can't click into that one, so
that's how, like you know, it
is going to be elaborating.
So each and every service
with its dependencies.
So that's a lower part of
the picture is showing.
You can do all these
things from one place.
Again, each and every
tile, you can click on it
like a recursion basis.
You can keep doing, like you know,
the drilling down till
the way you wanted it.
So how you do navigate the map?
So as I said, like you know, we can group
by the way you wanted it.
By default the grouping
is the related services,
how you are sending the metrics.
But as I said, like you
know, you can go ahead
and then group it, and then
you can zoom it and zoom out,
and all those things, because it's a map.
So wherever you need the
attention, you can zoom in
and then zoom out, and
then do all those things.
And also like you know, if you
see in the right hand drawer,
there is a something called,
like you know, there is a lot
of details around it, starting
with your health metrics of your services.
So in this case, like you know,
I do have a pet clinic, printing,
which is showing, like you
know, how healthy my services,
how many faults I'm getting it,
and then if I created any
SLOs, how they are healthy
or unhealthy, those kind of information.
In addition to that, as I mentioned,
you will be seeing all your
RED metrics, the number
of requests you're getting
at, your errors, faults,
then latency, all that
information is available.
And one additional thing is, the support
that we recently added
is, there is something
called operational audit.
So operational audit is
something like we are proactively
saying to you that hey,
this x servers is having
some latency issues,
can you take a look into it?
So it is not, like you know, the reactive
days allowed on and on, right?
Like you know, now
people wanted to do more
of proactive stuff.
So in this case, like you
know, it will tell you,
so not only tell you, like you know,
there is something happening,
but if you wanted to take
a deep dive, you just click
on that 1.1 of the traces
that it will be showing you,
and then it will tell you
exactly like how it is coming
to the conclusion that
it needs some attention.
So let's switch gears
and then talk about real user monitoring.
So real user monitoring
as I said, like you know,
if you wanted to record
all your user interactions
from browsers, like you know,
your end user might be
using their browsers
to get like, you know, some
insights from their browsers.
You might be using real user monitoring.
And we have been supporting,
like you know, this web
for a pretty long time, and
we recently added the support
for both Android and iOS.
And with this one, like you know,
you can get a lot of
information around it.
Like for example, again, how
healthy is your application
or, like you know, both
mobile as well as web.
And then in terms of web,
you will be having a lot
of details around how many
JavaScript errors I'm getting
or, like you know, is
there any JavaScript errors
or in the mobile world, like you know,
it could be like in the number of crashes,
those kind of stuff, right?
So it'll be getting, like you
know, numerous information
from this particular charts.
And also like you know, when
we are extending to mobile,
so these are all some
of the charts you are getting it, right?
First one is like comprehensive dashboard.
So that's where, like
you know, you will be
seeing both your performance metrics,
and then your crash analytics
on all those information,
and all these things
are coming in real time.
So when a customer is getting a crash
from their mobile application,
it will be recorded
in Application Signals or
real user monitoring, so that,
like you know, there is not
much leniency there, right?
So the moment they are getting it,
you are getting it in real time.
And also, like you know,
when we are talking to many
of the mobile app people, they wanted
to see, like you know,
the important things
around how much time my
app is taking to load,
or, like you know, the
application performance index,
those kind of things.
Again, the mobile world is splitted,
like, you know there is
a iOS, there is Android,
and then here, like you
know, in Android world,
we call it as ANR, or
application not responding.
But in the iOS world we call
it as crash analytics, right?
So depending on the kind
of mobile application
we are talking about,
we provide you both information
in the same language
that the mobile developers
are using, right?
So if you are using iOS,
we'll show you all the crash analytics.
And if you're using Android,
we'll be showing all the ANR details.
So with this one, like
you know, you are also
getting, like you know,
the various information
like, which iOS they are running
or which version of
Android they are running,
what type of device they're using.
So all those kind of
information, we are capturing it,
and then those information
are available to you.
So we talked about, like you know,
two different things, right?
One is your services which
are running in the backend,
and then the another world
is the real user monitoring,
which could be, like you
know, web or mobile, right?
How they are interconnected
with each other?
So for that, like you know,
we are using correlation IDs.
The moment, like you
know, your customer is
doing some operation, we
will create a correlation ID,
and then that correlation
ID is being tracked
over multiple hops.
So this is based on
OpenTelemetry, open standards.
And again, like you know, the
end-to-end transaction tracing
is available for you.
So once there is an
error that is happening,
you can easily track it all the way
from your mobile application
to your backend service.
And also with this newer
application map feature,
you'll be having automatic
topology discovery as well
as visualization so that
from one place you'll be able
to see how things are
interconnected with each other.
And also it is showing you the
service dependency as well.
So you might be wondering, like you know,
how my A is calling B and
all those information,
that is also available for you.
And also the performance
metrics overlay at each tier.
I don't know whether you noticed it,
every tile will be having a donut chart.
So the donut chart is color coded.
So every chart,
when you are having, like
you know, some issues,
it will be showing in red.
So that needs, like you know,
it needs some attention, right?
So on a high level,
if it is, like you know,
a thousand foot overview
of your application, you can
easily see, like you know,
which tile is showing you red or green,
those kind of information,
so that it's easy
for you to figure out what's going on.
So it's easy for this
bottleneck identification
and visual indicators
using that one, right?
So with that one, like you know,
this is how the architecture is.
From your mobile
applications, you are sending,
whether it is iOS or Android,
you are sending your telemetry
to CloudWatch real user monitoring.
From CloudWatch real user monitoring,
we will do the job of taking those metrics
and then sending it to
Application Signals.
And in that bottom side, like you know,
you have your backend services.
So with this backend services,
you are sending your telemetry as well.
Again, everywhere it is via
OpenTelemetry, open standards.
And if you are a user, so
in this case, like you know,
assume we are seeing
from the right hand side.
We are seeing from the right hand side
with this Application
Signals and application map.
So using that, not only you're going
to monitor your applications,
and if something is breaking,
we are gonna see, like you
know, how you're gonna fix it.
So that's what all about
the code we will be
showing you from Alex.
So with that one, like you
know, let's go with the code.
- [Alex] Hi, everyone.
A software engineers
and system architects,
how many times have you looked
at the architecture diagram,
something like this, and
thought to yourself, well,
this is like some really ugly
spaghetti monster right there.
And how many of you actually
build a system like that?
I did. My name is Alex Nazarov.
I'm a principal engineer in CloudWatch.
Many projects start with
simple, beautiful architecture,
but then your business
grows, you add features,
you add redundancy, you add security,
you add search index, you add analytics,
this list goes on and on.
And so you get the idea.
Eventually the system becomes
so difficult to comprehend.
Even people who build that
system, six months down the road,
will have hard time
understanding what's happening
under the hood.
You see, the problem is not
that distributed systems
are over-engineered.
The reality is that real user scenarios,
real life scenarios requires
building complex systems.
And this system stretching
human abilities to understand
and keep track of what's
going on in the system.
So when we approach this challenge,
we talked to our customers.
And they said, "You know what?
Instead of this, I want to have a way
to look at all that I
have in all my accounts
on one page, kind of like this.
So show me on the high level what I have,
and also help me to understand the status
of like health status of each application.
But when I'm interested,
I wanna dive deep,
like, go inside and see its gut,
see what's happening under the hood,
but then I should be
able to go back, zoom out
and look it up on the high level."
So we used this as a guidance
when we worked on this
new application map.
What we introduced here
is dynamic grouping.
So what Application Signals
in this map is trying to do
at its best effort is
to discover resources
like API gateways, load
balancers, EKS, ECS clusters,
EC2 auto scaling groups, and
use them as a backbone that,
or like a tip of the iceberg,
to present a structure
that forms applications
that you're hosting on AWS.
Previously, Application
Signals only worked
with instrumented sources.
You would have to instrument your code.
But we just recently added functionality
that like I highlighted on
this map with the dotted lines,
these are the applications that we believe
just entry points into
something much bigger.
It's not instrumented
but you still have all the benefits
that like minimalistic PM
functionality for these services.
So for example, I have this
ticketing lite service.
It essentially allows
customers submit tickets.
When I explore details
for this application,
I see first of all there
are, like, it discovered
four services under the hood.
It tells me, you know,
it's bridging some SLOs.
These are the most recent
deployments for this application.
This is taken from CloudTrail,
and the golden signal metrics
like availability, some latency,
server faults, user errors.
I can go dive inside of it.
And again, everything
is a dotted line here.
It means it's not instrumented,
but it's pretty straightforward.
I have a API gateway,
and it has three Lambda functions
that implement some of the APIs
backed up by this list
tickets, read tickets,
submit tickets, pretty straightforward.
And even from this map, I already can see
that okay, I have issue
that my customers facing,
because it's an API gateway,
and then it's actually going
into the submit ticket.
So submit ticket has issues.
From this, you know, overall
description I can only see,
well, it got deployed recently.
The deployments are marked as
vertical lines on the graphs
but I don't see any
correlation with deployments.
So at this point, the
best idea for me would be
to instrument this application.
I can go and instrument each
individual Lambda separately.
Or on the high level,
I can just use, you
know, this context menu
to enable Application Signals
for all of the components
inside of this application.
So here I can just like
click, click, enable
on all the Lambdas.
What's gonna happen is
that this enablement will
add OpenTelemetry layer
to this Lambda functions.
It will not add the
agent, but only the SDK,
the client side, that will
talk to OTLP endpoint.
So the benefit of that is
that you actually not wasting
resources on the agent,
and it does not increase the,
the agent does not increase
the, from the cold start.
So I already, so the enablement
takes roughly five minutes.
So I already have a carbon copy
of that ticketing service over here
that is already instrumented.
So now when I look at instrumented version
of that application, I
see more details, right?
So now I can see that, okay,
this is that problematic
submit ticket Lambda,
but it also brought in another
Lambda and this SQS queue.
So this is how they
communicate this synchronously
with each other, also showing
me the tickets, DynamoDB table
that these Lambdas are using.
So I got much better picture
about what is actually
happening right now with my system.
And after instrumentation,
what is also available to me
is this operational audit.
On the high level,
operational audit just goes
finds what you would do
manually just find traces,
find exceptions, and
it just surfaces it up
so you can actually not
diving into the logs
or doing any complicated
research, you see exactly.
Okay, this Lambda called SQS,
and this is the exception message
that says well you're trying
to submit too big of a message
to the queue and it doesn't accept it.
And this is how we got that exception.
Now what's I wanna also show is
that this audit is available
from your dev environment,
like IDE, so in this case I'm showing Kiro
but VS Code with client
would do exactly same thing.
I have here pre-installed
CloudWatch Application Signals,
MCP server, and the way
to get it is actually,
it's available on
awslabs under mcp folder,
and there is a
cloudWatch-applicationsignals-mcp-server.
So what I can do now, this IDE talks
to the telemetry that captures the state
of my production, I
can ask questions like,
which services are breaching SLO?
And right now it actually
went, scanned that map,
list of services, figured out
which ones are breaching SLO
and reporting this to me.
And I can also with it individual
services, like I can say,
well, what's wrong with
that submit ticket, right?
So submit ticket is gonna like
execute public API available
that you can also use that,
runs the operational audit.
And from this operational audit,
it makes the same
conclusion that we just saw,
that message on the screen.
It's saying you trying
to submit messages bigger
than the queue can accept.
And the benefit of this is
that you can essentially
do your root cause analysis
troubleshooting from IDE,
and instantly connect your
code with what's happening
with your services in production.
And the IDE already knows, like,
because you loaded that code base in IDE,
it connects that stack trace
that it found in telemetry,
and it says which line of
code is causing this problem.
It suggests remediation or fixes,
how you can actually
mitigate that problem.
Okay, so now let's go back
and talk about how to customize this map.
So right now what you're
seeing here is best effort
to group all services,
what we call it, like, related services.
Essentially many applications
have an entry point
like a load balancer or some
front end service, API gateway,
and this is what we're
discovering and showing.
Yeah, like you have, you
know, this for example,
appointment service, it has
like this microservices,
this how they related to each other.
There are some components that
not connected with anything,
they have their own
like standalone version,
but we also allow you
to customize this map.
And so by default, you could
see also all the services
grouped by environment.
So by environment you
can use OTel attributes,
and say deployment.environment.name.
And that way, you can
differentiate your production
versus test performance, et cetera.
So that way, you can
regroup all your services by environment.
But in addition, we have
this way of custom grouping.
So it's a little bit involving,
but, so bear with me for a moment.
So let's say I would like
to have different groupings
of all the resources and
all the services I have
across multiple accounts.
So I would create this
groupings over here, like I want
to actually control, myself,
what composes my application.
So I have create a
grouping by application.
Another part that's
important to me is tiering,
like tier one, tier two service,
like, how it's important to my business.
And then team ownership.
I can, you know, assign services
to the teams who operate on them.
So this on the left
side, on the right side,
what I'm specifying here is AWS tags,
these are the tag names.
So if I have a name tag named
application or app.name,
or myapp on API gateway, the value
that this tag is carrying will be the name
of that application.
The same with the tier and the team.
So these are just AWS tags
that I'm saying should be used
to create grouping.
In addition to AWS tags,
we also support OTEL_RESOURCE_ATTRIBUTES.
I brought them here.
So OTEL_RESOURCE_ATTRIBUTES is
when you instrument your
code, you have a chance
to define additional key-value pairs
for this services that get instrumented
with OTel telemetry.
So, and this is what you would,
you could use alternatively to the tags.
You could use just
OTEL_RESOURCE_ATTRIBUTES
and pretty much do the same thing.
Specify that this microservice now belongs
to let's say, pet clinic application.
So after that is configured,
I'll, you know, give it some time,
and when telemetry gets
ingested into CloudWatch,
the application map will form
with these custom groupings.
So for example, this is the
grouping by application,
because I have annotated my telemetry,
or I annotated resources with AWS tags
with these values of telemetry.
And this is example of, let's say, tiers.
And this is how I can work.
I actually can chain this grouping by.
I could start with tiering.
Like, let's say the most important to me,
I wanna work on tier one
services, I see they all in red,
but I'm interested in
tier one first, right?
So I go inside and it's quite complicated.
So I can group on for the second level,
say well, now I just want
to see them by application.
Well, there actually three
different application
in tier one, payment, pet
clinic, ticketing system.
Then I can go essentially inside of them
and inspect that,
let's say, this application,
pet clinic, right?
Or I can go back completely, back up,
and regroup by applications
and see what's available in this account.
So let's actually dive into
pet clinic, and what this-
- [Siva] By the way, if you
have any questions, please
ask it, like you know, let's
make it as interactive.
If you have any questions,
please feel free
to ask any questions.
Sorry Alex.
- No worries.
So what we try to achieve here is for,
that's what, you know,
customer sentiment was.
I wanna use the map to guide me
to when I'm paged for example.
And so what this map is
highlighting, let's say,
four services in red,
they breaching their
service level objectives.
And besides that,
every component also shows,
it's like a health circle
that shows a breakdown between
server faults, user errors,
and successful requests.
And you can kind of gauge from
that where the problems are.
First of all, what's highlighted in red.
Second, if let's say, you didn't
set up any service level objectives,
you can just gauge from that circle.
The more red means, you know,
more problems essentially.
And you can like instantly
go and inspect each component
and get this operational audit.
And for example, in this
case, I get whole bunch
of, you know, these audit
cards that tell me, you know,
we have this problematic dependency
and it could set like some,
you know, unhandled edge case,
et cetera.
And this one is interesting,
one of the auditors
will try to find an outlier.
And by outlier I mean some
of the resources, like a pod
or a node or EC2 instance,
that contributing the most
to errors or to high
latencies in your application.
So this is, this audit card is
finding exactly this scenario
suggesting that you would want
to recycle this resource, right?
But it's all good
and great knowing what's
happening on the server side,
but sometimes we don't
have full visibility
into what's happening with the,
what the client experiences,
because the server side instrumentation
gives us so much, right?
And for that, there are two techniques
that CloudWatch suggests you could use.
One is synthetic canneries.
So this is an example of a whole bunch
of different synthetic canneries
that continuously running,
executing APIs, and
validating that AWS responses,
actually match the expected results.
And you can see like,
well, they're actually
not always succeeding.
There's a only 96% success rate,
but there is a also,
they call synthetics for a reason.
So they not fully represent
the actual customer experience.
And to measure that, CloudWatch
has real user monitoring.
So real user monitoring
is essentially a set
of APIs including the client side SDK
that you can use to instrument a website.
So like this example is
the app monitor that,
it just essentially a bunch of JavaScripts
that included with a website,
that continuously measuring
and reporting back home
about how these pages
are loading, how fast,
are there any JavaScript there, et cetera.
And what we just recently launched
is a similar client side instrumentation
for Android applications
and for iOS applications.
So that way, when you look
at this application map,
you're not only seeing how
your services are performing,
but you're also seeing what
your customers are experiencing.
And so from this picture I
could say that, like again,
there's a health status
circle, it tells me that, well,
the Android customers are
really having a bad day.
I have too many crashes,
like also server faults,
and these graphs, they kind
of support that, they just
seeing how historically
those issues been happening.
So at this point, I would
like to troubleshoot more,
and get to the real user monitoring part
of the AWS console.
So in here, real user monitors
in Application Signals,
that they connected with the service,
that this, you know, client
applications are hitting first,
like in this case, it's
a pet planning front end.
And I have three different
real user monitors
for this microservice.
So this one is for website,
this one is for, sorry,
this one for iOS, this one is for website
and this one is for Android.
And I could tell from here, from details,
which pages or screens
actually having issues
in Android application.
And so like, this is a number of crashes.
And so the owner details
activity is the one
that has the most problems.
To troubleshoot even
further, like first of all,
I can go and use Android
Studio, so I have it preloaded,
to validate like, is
this actually happening,
so I can go check on
list of all the owners.
So I'm running a simulation
of this, of OLAP,
and when I click a individual owner,
it essentially resets.
So I do see that this
application is crashing
on that particular screen.
So to root cause it even further,
I can click on any data
point on the crashes graph,
and we'll get like
essentially a list of sessions
that resulted in application crashes.
So this data is transferred
from the mobile app
to RUM service,
and at this point I can
just, you know, spot check.
For example, I pick a session,
and I get transferred to RUM console,
and then here I can look at the exception.
So this is the stack
trace for this exception.
I can just go and transfer it
back to the Android Studio,
analyze this stack
trace, and essentially go
to the line that causing the issue.
Just help me to understand where I need
to implement the fix.
So enabling RUM for
mobile, and I'm gonna show
for Android, it's very straightforward.
So there's one more, there
is one dependency you need
to include in your, you know, build file,
which is OTel SDK, but
it's packaged by Amazon.
We just picked all the
pieces needed from OTel
to support that functionality.
And you also need to create app monitor,
and specified in the configuration file
that this application will be recorded
through this RUM monitor,
and just specify the region
where the telemetry will flow.
And that's how to set it up.
And if I go back, just one
thing I wanted to summarize is
that application map is
acting essentially as a guiding tool.
You can think of it as a dashboard,
but interactive dashboard.
From this dashboard,
you're not only looking
just at metrics and graphs,
you're looking at your life system,
how it performs at the
moment or historically,
you can go and check different time.
Let's say you, if you're
investigating an event
that happened last night or two weeks ago,
you can change the timeframe
and go back to that time
and see, it will historically
show how your system behaved
at that time.
And you're not only seeing
how your services performing
or how your resources
responding to requests,
but now you also with mobile RUM,
you can also see end user experience.
And essentially that way,
oversee all your distributed
system from start to end.
So Application Signals what it does,
it, after you instrument it,
it actually connects metrics,
logs, and traces together.
So for example, in Lambda
it's pretty straightforward.
There's Lambda logs,
and traces, and metrics.
For let's say EKS, it's a
little bit more involving
but it's still, you know,
relatively straightforward.
So in fact, traces in CloudWatch,
they do report, they connect
which log group to go
for corresponding logs.
And so like, I can show
one of the examples.
So when I'm troubleshooting the service,
let's say, this is a
microservice, could be JS or.
And have this bunch of operations,
and this operation is
like obviously failing.
And at this point this
is where the sidebar
connects all this other telemetry.
So on the left, you see the metrics.
Here you see correspondent
spans to the metric,
but this is the link to application log.
And the similar would happen
for let's say EKS application log,
and you can let's say,
Application Signals could not
connect the dots, you could
customize your trace attributes
and add which logs to look for
when that trace is emitted.
- [Siva] And also, like
you know, we have a,
maybe you wanna show the
transaction search feature.
So what we do is, like you know,
we take your transactions
in terms of traces,
and then convert and then store as logs.
So that way, like you
know, you can go ahead
and then just search for it, anything.
So an ideal use case
could be, like you know,
if you are a, maybe a support person
and then you're getting a call,
and then the customer saying like,
"Hey, my our order is not
going through," all you need
to ask them is like, "Hey,
what is your order number?"
Just go to the transaction search page,
click that, like, you
know, order.id is 123,
something like that, right?
And then the moment you click Enter,
it is gonna take all the
traces or all the transactions
that has happened in the
last three hours for example.
And then it'll show you all
the transactions in that one,
wherever we are using
this order.id is 123.
So this is, like you
know, finding a needle
in the haystack kind of a situation.
And with this transaction search feature,
because we are taking your traces
and then storing as
logs, you can do all kind
of operations, typically,
however you're doing it
with your logs, right?
So maybe, so this is what the
transaction search feature is,
so Alex can guide you on that.
- [Alex] Yeah, the transaction
search already also
getting benefit of discovered
services, it will help you.
It will suggest, okay, you can search
through this microservice,
through this API,
and that will also help you
with like which fields
you can specify in here.
And maybe some of the
fields will be, you know,
this is my request ID, I know the request,
or this is my order ID,
and you can that way nail down.
But I think the point,
what Siva was making is
that traces in Application
Signals, they store that as logs,
and that way you can use
log analytics essentially
to better reason about
your application behavior.
- [Participant] A follow up,
if I've already instrumented
for X-Ray, will I need to instrument again
for OpenTelemetry?
- No.
- Okay.
- [Alex] There is one, you know, caveat.
So when X-Ray originally
launched, it has its own SDK,
which is we announced
that's on deprecation
path quite a while back,
and I don't know some people
still use that, right,
that X-Rays SDK.
But I guess starting few years back,
we announced that moving
forward, OTel SDK is the one
that X-Ray will support in the future,
and we call it Amazon
Distribution of OTel, ADOT.
And the reason for that,
actually all of that,
you can assemble it yourself as well.
It's all in public repo.
We just pre-built it so it's easier
to make sure all the necessary
pieces are in one place.
- [Siva] So this particular
QR code has a bunch of links,
so if you want to see that,
so whatever Igor, sorry,
Alex has talked about, all
these things are available
in that one observability workshop.
So we have Application Signals demo also.
So all these things are
interactively available,
so that you don't have
to create any accounts
and then try all those features.
So, and also, like you know,
we have a YouTube show called
"Cloud Operation Show,"
so that runs every two weeks, Thursdays.
So that, recorded videos
also available there, and we
do have a separate observability
best practices guide.
So we have been talking
to hundreds of customers,
and we identify the patterns,
and then we document all that information.
So that information is also available.
Please take a look into it.
And then if you have any
interest, like you know,
any follow up or anything,
please reach out to us.
So this is our LinkedIn
handles. Please feel free.
- Thanks everyone.
- Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)